porsche has a storied history at the
moles since the race started in 1923
they have clocked the most wins
this porsche 956 it was the 1982 entry
in limones then raced for about 10 years
the doors are feather-light weight but
for the last 16 years Porsche has SAT
the race out this weekend they got back
in the racing pedigree has fed into its
road cars even the SUV's that now make
up sixty percent of its sales we always
say we have sports cars with two doors
and they have sports cars with photos
and mccann and cayenne is also a sports
car is for the worse our target is to
have always the most sporty car in every
segment and as long as we do that we are
we are satisfied we're here in the
garage the workshop of Porsches museum
we have here a nineteen sixty followed
by nine eleven 65 and then a 71 it's a
tribute to Portia's sports car past but
their challenge is to make sure their
future SUVs are sporty and fun as these
cars but there's one thing threatening
the fun regulation
there are some political hazards also in
Germany and also in in Europe because
all these questions in terms of co2
regulations are very demanding for the
car industry
one concern they don't have price the
Porsche 918 at eight hundred and forty
five thousand dollars it's the most
expensive car in the company's history
zero to 60 and 2.5 seconds and it's as
exclusive as it is expensive only 918 of
the 918's were made we have more than
two third are sold so if you want one
you have to hurry up hans nichols
bloomberg stuttgart